JEFF POSNICK: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to this week's episode
of YouTube Developers Live.
This week we're going to be
focusing on a topic near and
dear to my heart, which is
debugging issues with YouTube
data APIs and YouTube player
APIs and some best practices
for how to obtain help whenever
you do run into an
issue that you're not able
to debug yourself.
Apologies for the folks who
wanted to watch along with the
show live, but we're actually
doing a recorded, semi-live
version of the show.
I assure you that I am live.
The API calls we'll be making
will be live, so hopefully
that will be able to suffice
for everybody.
And I also wanted to point out
that this is probably going to
be a little bit shorter than
our normal shows where
we have guests on.
But hopefully, it'll have some
nice focused content for
everybody to dig into.
So let's jump right
into things.
I wanted to just, as I
mentioned, emphasize the fact
that we want to make it possible
for folks to help
themselves.
When you are running into an
error, usually the API will
give you the information that
you need in order to figure
out what's going on and to solve
the problem by yourself.
And that's the ideal case.
But we also want to help you
get the techniques that you
know to report really meaningful
issues to us.
If you happen to notice
something and it's clear that
there is some sort of bug,
there's certain pieces of
information, certain steps that
we need on the Developer
Relations team side to really
effectively help you.
So we'll cover some techniques
for getting that as well.
Let's dig right in.
And we're going to start
by talking about the
YouTube Data APIs.
Data APIs is kind of like a
big umbrella right now.
So I'm talking about YouTube
Data API, Version 3.
A lot of what I'm saying also
applies to the Analytics API.
A lot of what I'm saying will
apply to Version 2 of the Data
API, so I'll just say Data API
as a kind of catch-all.
And the one thing that's
probably more important than
anything else that I wanted to
point out about the Data APIs
is that they always
return a response.
This is a RESTful API.
Every request is
made via HTTP.
So you send our service
an HTTP request.
We will send you back
an HTTP response.
Now, that doesn't always mean
that it's going to be a
successful API request.
That HTTP response might have
an error associated with it.
But we should always give you
something that is hopefully
meaningful enough to debug
whatever's going on with your
request and to identify
the problem.
So more important than anything
else, know that you
should always get back a
response from the API.
And I sometimes see folks who
raise questions in Stack
Overflow or the issue tracker
and they say, I'm not getting
a response back from the API.
Really, the only case that that
should happen, where you
don't hear anything back, is
when your request never makes
it to our server
to begin with.
And this sometimes happens
because people are on fairly
complicated network setups, or
maybe they're behind some sort
of firewall and access to
Google's API servers happen to
be blocked on their network.
If you're in that situation,
there's not so much that we
can do to help you.
Talking to your network
administrator or just trying
to fiddle around with settings,
or try it on a
different computer, on a
different network, all those
are steps that you would have
to take in order to resolve
those sorts of issues.
But that's kind of
an edge case.
So for the folks who know how
HTTP request and responses
work, you always get back an
HTTP response code, and you
also get back a status line
associated with that code.
And usually, and certainly for
requests made against our API
servers, you'll get back
an HTTP response body.
So a combination of that HTTP
response code, the status line
for that response, and the
response body is the
information that you need as a
developer to figure out what's
going wrong with
your API calls.
It's not sufficient a lot of
times to just look at the
response code.
A lot of times people will say,
hey, I'm getting back an
HTTP 403 error when I
make this API call.
There are only a certain number
of valid HTTP response
codes, so some of them are
overloaded and reused for
different types of errors.
HTTP 403s usually have to
do with unauthorized
or forbidden requests.
Even trying to come up with all
the potential things on
the top of my head is
a little difficult
because there's a lot.
So a lot of times, the only way
to figure out what's going
on is to look at the actual
body of the HTTP response.
And in that body, you'll
see more details about
what caused the error.
So it might be a quota error.
It might be due to using the
credentials for a different
account when trying to access
the authorized information of
a completely separate account.
It might be because you're
trying to access information
that somebody has decided they
don't want to make public,
like their list of favorite
videos or something like that.
There are specific error codes
that will be in the response
body associated with each of
those types of failure.
And, again, you need to look.
So the question that everybody
should ask us as a followup
for that is exactly
how do I look?
A lot of times, your interaction
with our API is
via our client libraries, and
our client libraries do a
great job of simplifying a
lot of common use cases.
It makes it really easy
to make requests.
It makes it really easy to
deal with responses.
But it also handles a lot of the
details for you, including
taking the HTTP response, and
de-serializing it, and
converting into a Python object
or a Java object or
something like that.
So most of the time, the client
libraries will, when
they see an HTTP error response,
turn that into an
exception that gets raised by
the Native Client Library.
And this is a perfectly fine
way of interacting with the
API and handling things, because
the exception object
that gets created-- and again,
the specifics vary from the
Python client library, the Java
library, things like that.
But for the most part, there are
going to be accessors on
that exception object where you
can get that underlying
information about the HTTP error
response, including with
the error code what the HTTP
response code was, the status
line, the response body,
all that sort of thing.
But sometimes you have to know
exactly where to look and
maybe you're not just handling
exceptions by properly looking
at all the properties and
getting the details.
Maybe you just happen to be
logging whatever the string
representation of the exception
is, and that makes
it a little bit difficult
for you to figure out
what's going on.
So in that situation, your
best friend is basically
turning on HTTP-level logging
in the client libraries.
And the reason that you have to
turn on the client library
level is that certainly for
all of our newer APIs--
and it's actually now the
default for Version
2 of the Data API--
all requests are made
using HTTPS.
So if you've ever made HTTP
requests, you could fire up a
network monitoring tool like
Wire Shark and just take a
look at that raw HTTP traffic
as it's being sent out.
You could obviously see some
information that you might not
want to be explored in plain
text across the internet
though, so we are now using
HTTPS for everything.
And in order to take a look at
that raw data, you need to
make a change in the client
library to enable log in.
So I'm going to just quickly
walk through the steps for the
Python client library making a
v3 Data API call and show you
how to turn on that HTTP logging
and what the output
looks like.
So I'm going to quickly go to
my terminal, make this a
little bit bigger, too, and if
you run this code, it's a
basic my_channel.py.
So I'll pull up the code in a
second, but just to show you
what's happening over here,
I'm getting back
an HTTP error 400.
It's telling me what it's
requesting, and it's saying no
filter selected.
So all I'm doing over here is
relying on the Python client
library's default behavior of
printing out the exception
when it dies.
So this actually is pretty
good, and that's great.
The Python client library does
a good job of exposing really
useful information during
just the default
display of the exception.
But let's say I wanted to see
the exact HTTP request that's
being made and the response
headers and
everything like that.
And we'll get into a little bit
later why you might want
to get that information for
debugging purposes.
So I'm going to pull up
the code over here.
This is a little bit of a
contrived example because I
explicitly did something wrong
in this code to make it fail.
But I'm basically going to be
taking this line and just bump
that up a little bit
if I could remember
how to do it here.
I'm not sure.
But if you could see this, this
is httplib2.debug level
setting equal to 4.
And I'll include a link to the
docs that explain how to do
that for the Python
client library.
So this is basically telling
the Python client library,
hey, I would like you to turn
on the highest level of
debugging for all of your HTTP
requests that you are making.
So let's just see how
un-commenting that line
changes things around.
So in this case, you could see
all the HTTP requests that are
being made, and you can
see the response.
And this is on the
raw HTTP level.
So you see over here, for
instance, this is the
authorization token
that I'm using.
This is the actual URL that's
being requested.
It's making channels,
get request against
Googleapis.com, so that
all looks fine.
And I'm getting back an
HTTP 400 bad request.
And in this particular case,
I happen to know what the
problem is.
It's because I don't have
mine=true sets,
so there's no filter.
So if I just run that again,
you can see I get back, in
this case, an HTTP
200 response.
So everything worked fine
in this particular case.
So this is something that's
specific to each client
library, like I said.
So you kind of have to look up
the documentation for each
client library and see how to
turn on HTTP request logging,
but it's super important.
And it's a really great
debugging technique.
So the other way you could debug
calls made to the API
without having to actually turn
on HTTP logging is to
make those calls in like a
sandbox type of context.
And what we could have--
the provide side is the API's
explorer, which lets you
experiment with all sorts of
Data API calls in this really
friendly web interface.
And I'm just going to make
the same sort of
request over here.
Let me actually just
do a search.list.
So I'm going to put in, well,
actually, let me just do it
without anything over here.
So this just lets you make your
same Data API requests
that you can make from code
within this web browser.
And you see all the different
options you can set.
So let me just not
put in anything.
And I know that's going to be
an error because you need to
set some filters and say what
you want your parts.
So if you look over here, you
can see that this will give
you the underlying HTTP request
that's being made and
the response in a really
nice format.
And it makes it easy to read.
It makes it easy to pass it
along to Stack Overflow or the
issue tracker when you're
asking for help.
So you'll see over here, you
get back this error--
required parameter part--
and that gives you a pretty
clear explanation.
Hey, I need to put in a part if
I want to make my request.
So I'm going to say
over here part ID.
I'm going to re-run
my request.
And in this case, I
get back results.
So this is good for both trying
to replicate a request
that's giving you an
error when you're
using a client library.
You could just try to find the
corresponding method in this
API's explorer and make the
request from there and see
what the response is in a
really friendly format.
One other thing to point out
is that a lot of requests,
certainly for the Analytics
API and some of the other
APIs, but even some Data API
requests, require that you go
through the OAuth2 flow before
you can make those requests.
You can do that directly
from the API explorer.
So just because you're making an
authorized request does not
mean you have to use
a client library.
You could play around with
the API explorer
in that case, too.
We have a brand new page in
our docs that is really
awesome that--
also if you're into the sort of
thing like I am, that gives
you a full breakdown of all the
different types of errors
that you could get back
from doing Data
API Version 3 requests.
So this gives you kind of an
atlas for things that could go
wrong and what you could kind
of prepare yourself for.
So it's broken down into general
errors, the type of
things that could happen for
any request, regardless of
which service you're
going against.
These are the things that
you'd expect like what
exceeded or bad requests
with bad filters
or things like that.
There's also, for specific API
calls like for doing a search,
invalid search filter,
invalid video ID.
So if you happen to get a
specific error code, you can
look it up on this page, and you
can see a little bit more
detail in the description field
for the possible causes.
And in some cases, understanding
the causes
should hopefully give you an
idea of how to fix the
underlying problem.
That's pretty much what I wanted
to talk about on the
Data API side of things.
There's a completely different
API that folks are probably
familiar with as well and
that's the Player API.
And the Player API is, as the
name suggests, used for
playing back YouTube videos.
And we'll just talk about the
Player API in the context of
embeds on web pages right now.
I know a lot of folks might be
using the newer Android Player
API for embedding YouTube
videos in Android
applications.
And what I'm going to talk
about is not necessarily
related to that, but more
about the web embeds and
debugging those.
So the most important thing to
keep in mind for web embeds is
that things can go wrong.
The common way of handling and
reporting errors back to
developers when things do go
wrong, when you use the Web
Embed API, is via an
On Error Handler.
So this is a specific JavaScript
event handler that
will get fired whenever
something happens
that impacts playback.
So I'm going to do a quick
live example of
how that might work.
So I'm going to pull up the
Player API over here.
I'm going to grab a sample from
our Getting Started guide
for using Player API.
This is a full working
example.
I'm going to pull up a site
called jsfiddle, which I
happen to like for doing live
JavaScript testing things.
I'm going to paste this
right in here.
This gives you a kind of
playground where you can host
HTML, JavaScript, and CSS, and
it provides you with a URL
that you can then pass along
to somebody else.
And they could run your
code and see exactly
what the output is.
So this is super, super useful
for debugging things in kind
of a clean environment but also
for reporting problems.
If you do happen to have any
sort of errors that you're
really not sure about with the
Player API, a lot of the times
what we'll ask for is that you
provide a simple reproduction
of the issue.
Sometimes we'll say, hey, you
can give us the full site URL
for your live production site,
and we can see the error
within the context
of a bigger page.
But if it's really just like
a standalone, easily
reproducible problem, putting it
on something like jsfiddle,
and I'm sure there are other
sites out there that do
something similar, gives us a
really good way of being able
to look at the specific code.
We can then go and edit the code
and play around a bit and
try things out and try
making some changes.
So I highly recommend it.
So what I did over here is
take the code from the
documentation for using
the iframe Player API.
And I pasted it into the HTML
frame within jsfiddle, and I'm
going to click Run right now.
So this is fortunately actually
working, because we
do strive to have working code
within our documentation.
So everything looks good.
In this case, it loads
up the sample video.
Things are great.
I want to show you how you can
deal with an error situation.
I'm going to bump up the size
over here of some things in
order to make this a little
bit more visible.
So you can see that in the
iframe player, we have the
ability to define a bunch of
events where handlers are
fired in response to different
API states, so things like the
API being ready or on the state
change like when the
video pauses or plays
or so on.
The example we have in the docs
doesn't show using the
OnError handler, but I could
quickly put that in.
So there's another event
called OnError
that could be fired.
And I'm going to create an
inline anonymous function to
handle it and go over here and
do the hold alerts, and error,
and in this case, I
want to do e.data.
So the OnError handler gets
passed in as parameter E, and
the data property of E will
have the error code in it.
So if I run it now, nothing's
going to happen because we
have this great code, and
there's no errors.
But it's pretty easy to create
an error with the Player API,
for instance, if you have
an invalid video ID
that you try to load.
So let me just put in a bunch
of junk at the end of the
video ID and try and
run that again.
And what we should see
is an OnError occur.
Let me try that one more time.
No.
Something happened.
I could spend a little bit more
time looking into this,
but I don't want to take away
from the rest of the show.
Basically, if anything does go
wrong, this OnError handler
should fire off.
And in this case, I was
trying to just alert
for the error message.
I'm not exactly sure why it's
not happening, but in a real
application, you could do
any variety of steps.
You could log it to some sort
of remote JavaScript login
console you have set up.
You could take action by trying
to load in the next
video when an error occurs.
You could do any number
of different things.
The Player API has in the
documentation a list of
potential error codes that you
might run into similar to that
list from the Data API and
things like error code 2 for
an invalid video ID, 5 if the
video can't be played in the
HTML5 player, and a few
other things here.
So this is where that's
documented.
I wanted to just give you the
best practices, and I've kind
of touched on these in the
course of talking about the
ways of getting debugging
information.
But the absolute at a minimum
useful information that we
need when you're reporting an
error to us either in Stack
Overflow or issue tracker in
order to effectively figure
out what's going on and to help
you with your problem.
So we really, really want the
HTTP request and response
trace if you're running into an
issue with the Data APIs.
This includes both the HTTP
request headers and HTTP
response headers and
response body.
This really should be sufficient
information to
figure out pretty much
any problem.
If you are person posting this
in a public forum, you
probably do want to remove your
authorization value, even
though Oauth2 tokens do
expire after an hour.
But you still probably don't
want to post that publicly.
But pretty much everything else
other than that token you
could post publicly.
And that will give us enough
information to figure out what
your request is, what you're
getting back, do any sort of
cross-referencing with our
internal logs that we need to
do, and hopefully find the
solution to your problem.
So that's really the best
information you can provide to
us when you're running into an
error with the Data APIs.
On the Player API side of
things, like I mentioned, a
live reproduction on your
production site
is certainly good.
If it's something very specific
to the way your page
layout is and maybe you have a
few different plugins running,
and you're using jQuery and
something else, and you really
can only reproduce a problem
on a full website, then
definitely give us
that site's URL.
But the better way to do it is
probably to use something like
jsfiddle and create
a very minimal
reproduction of the problem.
And we'll take a look
at that jsfiddle.
We can edit it a little bit, and
we can play around with it
live and try to figure
out what's going on.
So that's really what we're
looking for when you're trying
to give us information.
And that's just ways for you to
help us help you by giving
us all the information we
need right up front.
And that's pretty much what I
wanted to cover in terms of
debugging and error
handling and best
practices in that space.
And I wanted to do a quick shout
out to the folks who
were able to make it to
our Los Angeles video.
We did a YouTube plus Google TV
video hackathon about two
weeks ago now.
So thanks for all the folks
who came out to that.
It was great meeting a
lot of you in person.
And I think next week, we're
going to be returning to more
of our traditional sit down
show with some guest
developers who are using API.
And I think that's going
to be a great show.
So stay tuned for that
at the same time.
Thanks everybody.
Jeff Posnick signing off.